>> STAY HEALTHY.
I WILL TALK TO YOU SOON.
>>> BROOM HEAD IS A
CONSERVATIVE.
HE VALUES THE INTEGRITY OF
INFORMATION AND THE TRUTH.
THAT'S WHY HE TELLS YOU THINKS
HE THINKS HE CAN VERIFY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE, NOT
HIM, PUTTING OUT MISINFORMATION.
THAT'S A FORM OF DISEASE ALSO.
SADLY, IT IS SPREAD BY
LEADERSHIP AS WELL.
THERE'S EVIDENCE OF THIS IN A
BIZARRE MOMENT FROM TODAY'S
SENATE HEARING.
A REPUBLICAN BADGERING SECRETARY
OF STATE BLINKEN, WHO BY THE WAY
HAS TOUGH QUESTIONS TO ANSWER
AND HE HASN'T ANSWERED THEM ALL
WELL, BUT NONSENSE ABOUT
PRESSING A BUTTON TO CUT OFF
BIDEN.
THIS IS THE KIND OF STUFF THAT
YOU HAVE TO TAKE
>>> LASH #BOLO.
MORE REPUBLICANS ARE BUYING INTO
THE LIE THERE IS A SECRET BUTTON
PUSHER WITH THE POWER TO MUTE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
HERE IS ANTHONY BLINKEN ABOUT
THIS.
>> SOMEBODY IN THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO PRESS THE
BUTTON AND STOP THE PRESIDENT,
CUT OFF THE PRESIDENT'S SPEAKING
ABILITY.
WHO IS THAT PERSON?
SOMEBODY HAS THE ABILITY TO PUSH
THE BUTTON AND CUT OFF HIS SOUND
AND STOP HIM FROM SPEAKING.
WHO IS THAT PERSON?
>> THERE IS NO SUCH PERSON.
>> ARE YOU TELLING THIS
COMMITTEE THAT THIS DOES NOT
HAPPEN, THAT THERE IS NO ONE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE WHO PUSHES THE
BUTTON AND CUTS HIM OFF MID
SENTENCE?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> YOU'RE TELLING US YOU DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THIS, THAT
SOMEBODY CUTS HIM OFF IN MID
SENTENCE?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE TELLING THIS
COMM
COMMITTEE?
>> SENATOR, I'M TELLING YOU
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE
PRESIDENT THE LAST 20 YEARS
ANYONE WHO TRIED TO STOP HIM
FROM SAYING WHAT HE WANTED TO
SAY, SPEAKING HIS MIND WOULD
PROBABLY NOT BE ALONG FOR THEIR
JOB.
>> WHAT'S THE FACT?
THE MUTE BUTTON THAT IS REFERRED
TO ORIGINATES FROM AN RNC TWEET
THAT HONES IN ON A WHITE HOUSE
FEED THAT CUTS OFF AS BIDEN
SPEAKS TO OFFICIALS ABOUT THE
FIRE CRISIS OUT WEST.
I GUESS IT'S TRUE.
WAIT.
THE RNC FAILS TO POINT OUT THAT
THE MOMENT IS LISTED ON THE
PRESIDENT'S SCHEDULE AS AN OUT
OF TOWN POOL SPRAY.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
ONE, IT MEANS MY MICROPHONE IS
FALLING OFF.
IS SOMEBODY STOPPING ME?
NO, JUST A MIKE FALLING OFF.
IT WAS PLANNED.
HERE IS THE POINT.
THE PRESS POOL FOLLOWING BIDEN
COMES IN BRIEFLY FOR PICTURES,
THEN THEY'RE USHERED OUT.
STANDING OPERATING PROCEDURE BUT
THE RIGHT HAS BEEN BUILDING THIS
LIE FOR MONTHS.
THEY'D RATHER IT BE SOMETHING
MORE LIKE THIS.
>> THIS PRESIDENCY FEELS LIKE A
NEVER ENDING SILVER ALERT EXCEPT
EVERY DAY WE WAKE UP AND REALIZE
THAT THIS MISSING SENIOR CITIZEN
IS ACTUALLY LIVING IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
AS THE COUNTRY IS BEING RUN INTO
THE GROUND BUT WHOEVER IS
PULLING HIS STRINGS.
YOU KNOW WHY PEOPLE ARE MUTING
JOE BIDEN?
JOE BIDEN CAN'T TALK ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS A WALKING CRINGE FEST.
>> THIS IS GUY THAT'S CLEARLY
NOT DOING WELL AND NOW JOE IS
CLEARLY GETTING WORSE.
>> LOOK, IT'S LUDICROUS BUT IT'S
DANGEROUS.
AGAIN, IT WAS A POOL SPRAY AND
THEN THEY CUT THE SOUND.
IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
THERE IS NO PERSON.
THERE IS NO BUTTON.
EVEN AFTER THIS EXCHANGE WITH
BLINKEN, HE WENT ON TRUMP TV TO
TALK MORE B.S.
>> FROM TIME TO TIME HIS SOUND
IS CUT OFF WHETHER IN THE WHITE
HOUSE OR OTHER PLACES.
SOMETIMES HE'S HUSTLED OFF THE
STAGE WHERE THE MEDIA CAN'T GET
ANSWERS.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO BE IN CHARGE.
>> I MEAN, LISTEN, THERE ARE SO
MANY LEGITIMATE THINGS TO GO
AFTER THE SIDE IN POWER.
WHY MAKE THINGS UP?
FROM THE SENIOR REPUBLICAN ON
THE SENATE FOREIGN RELATIONS
COMMITTEE, WHAT A SHAME.
AT A HEARING THAT SHOULD BE
ABOUT PRESSING BLINEN FOR REAL
ANSWERS ON A REAL CRISIS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND HIS COLLEAGUE
JOSH HAWLEY ISN'T DOING HIM ONE
BETTER THREATENING TO HOLD UP
EVERY CIVILIAN NOMINEE FOR THE
STATE AND DEFENSE DEPARTMENTS
UNLESS SECRETARY LLOYD AUSTIN,
BLINKEN AND JAKE SULLIVAN
RESIGN.
LOOK, ACCOUNTABILITY MATTERS BUT
THE SLOW WALK KEY PENTAGON
OFFICIALS WH